OVERTIME LOSS IN COLUMBUS
THURSDAY.HE
BOARDS.
HE HAS TO HAVE AN IMPACT IN.
NOW LARSSON THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
LARSSON BACK OUT HIGH.
THE SHOT BLOCKED BY MATT MARTINT
SLOW TO GET UP.
SCOTT MAYFIELD.
PL LOADED COLORADO
AVALANCHE LINE-UP LAST YEAR UP
IN DENVER.LER.
WE GET A WHISTLE HERE.
HAND PASS.
THEY GOING WIDE.
COYOTES WILL TRY TO GET IT OUT
HERE.
MATT FREE IT BEHIND THE
SENATORS.
RIPS THAT OVER HIM.
THIS IS O RIGHT AFTER.
>> Matt: KELLER LOOKING TO GET
IT OUT.
CAN'T  BY THE
MINNESOTA WILD. 1:39.
18 GOALS LAST
SCHMALTZES, THE
HE SENDS IT ACROSS.
>> Tyson: LET'S TAKE A
LYUBUSHKIN.
HE WILL TRY TO GO UP THE BOARDS.
O'BRIEN'S GOT IT.
HE WILL BANG IT OFF THE GLASS
AND OUT COMES BAILEY.
LEFTANOTHER AWAY
BY VEJMELKA.
THE COYOTES WILL COUNTER. MENTA.
THE ISLANDERS SEND IT IN THIS H,
I
PLAYING
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGERS CHANGIN.
CHIP AND CHASE.T.
HUNT THE PUCK DOWN.
THEY ARE GOING TO O UN TO FRONT.
HE SHOOTS!
THAT WENT OFFTHE SAVE.
THE PUCK COMES DOWN.
CT IS BOARD
HERE?
CROUSE IS IN THERE, TAKEN AWA
YOU SEE TIMMINS, YOUR DEFENSIVE
PARTNER, AND YOU CAN'T GO FOR
SO